ceos have a reputation of being
unempathetic profit-driven corporate
pigs in many cases ceos have little care
for the mental and physical health of
their employees and the only thing they
care about is overall employee output
unfortunately most of the famous ceos
and founders in the world exhibit many
of these characteristics and this has
caused many people to assume that
there's no such thing as a good ceo at
least not from an employee's perspective
but this is actually not the case
there are dozens of fortune 500 ceos
that are cherished by their employees
and the glassdoor regularly makes a list
of the most approved ceos in the world
based on the millions of employee
reviews on their website the executive
that tops the list is shantuna narayan
the ceo of adobe who enjoys an approval
rating of 99
now technically rich lesser did edge him
out in 2021 but if we go back to the
2019 list we'll see that rich lesser
doesn't even make the top hundred while
chanting is still number five i went
ahead and did the math and chantnu has
the highest average rank since 2019.
so here's how shantanu became the ceo of
adobe and skyrocketed the company while
also being an employee favorite
taking a look back chantanu was born on
may 27 1962 in hyderabad india he was
born to a pretty well-off family as his
father owned a plastics company and his
mother was an american literature
professor
despite his parents high status within
society chanting didn't really have any
massive ambitions as a kid
really all he wanted to do was become a
journalist and play qriket this is
actually a super interesting point as
satya nadella the ceo of microsoft and
another top-ranking ceo on the glassdoor
list also didn't have any massive
ambitions
it seems like there's an inverse
correlation between ambition and ego and
how good the individual is as a leader
anyway chantanu attended a local school
called hyderabad public school
when it came to picking a major shantanu
said that the only real options he had
were engineering and medicine and he was
extremely scared of blood so he went
with engineering a few years later
chanting graduated from osmania
university with a degree in electronics
and communications engineering he would
then turn around and secure a master's
in computer science from bowling green
state university in ohio in 1986
after completing his masters chantanoo
jumped into the workforce scoring a job
at measurex automation systems he worked
there for a few years before jumping to
apple in 1999 as a senior manager
unfortunately his tenure at apple was
during the worst time period for apple
maybe this was one of the reasons
shantanu was able to score a high level
management position though so it might
have been a good thing for shantanu
shantanu worked at apple up until 1995
when he left to become a director at
silicon graphics this didn't last too
long though and shantanu would find
himself creating his own startup during
the dotcom bubble chantenu and some of
his colleagues picked up on the rapid
trend towards digital photography so in
1996 they started a business called
piktra
pictra allowed users to share their
photos online similar to facebook and
instagram however after 12 to 14 months
in the business the team realized that
the market for an immigrant website
wasn't that mature not to mention it was
extremely hard to monetize so they
decided to try to sell the company to a
giant in the creative space adobe
unfortunately adobe didn't really care
about piktra but during the acquisition
meeting adobe did become extremely
impressed with shantanu they didn't
acquire pikra but they did offer
chantanu an extremely attractive
position as senior vice president of
worldwide product development as you
would guess chanting ditched pictures
shortly after and took on the role at
adobe in 1998. at adobe chanting's
biggest contribution before becoming ceo
was deal making throughout the late
1990s and early 2000s chantanu closed
350 deals for the company mostly with
media firms like vietcom cbs and pbs
this is why basically every media and
gaming website in the world used adobe
flash in the late 2000s and early 2010s
given chantinews incredible ability to
close lucrative deals i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that he was
promoted to ceo in 2005. just two years
later in 2007 bruce cheisen the ceo of
adobe at the time announced that he
would be stepping down and this allowed
continue to become the ceo of adobe in
december of 2007.
at the time adobe was in a rather
awkward position the company's stock had
gone sideways for seven years and it was
about to get crushed by the 2008
financial crisis
on top of this adobe had a major piracy
problem and adobe flash was about to get
squashed so chantenu had to revive adobe
and his first step in accomplishing this
was making adobe a subscription business
back in the day adobe came out with a
new photoshop and a new premiere pro
every year
you had versions like photoshop 2006 and
photoshop 2008 adobe sold these versions
as one-time purchases that consumers
could buy for a few hundred dollars and
use for life the problem though was that
most of these upgrades were rather small
and incremental and adobe only came out
with a major overhaul once every three
to five years given how expensive their
products were most customers simply
skipped the incremental upgrades and
only bought the major overhauls which
meant that adobe only made revenue from
each customer once every few years
shantanu addressed this shortfall by
making all of adobe's creative software
a subscription
most professional customers embraced
this change as it actually made more
sense for them as well
instead of dropping 500 on photoshop and
500 on premiere pro and 500 on after
effects every three years creative
professionals could pay 50 per month to
have the latest software from adobe at
all times on the other hand many people
complained about having to pay 50 per
month and many of you guys may think
that this is way too much in reality
it's not your fault for thinking that
and it's not adobe's fault for charging
that much this simply means that you're
not part of the target market that
adobe's targeting so chanting fought
piracy by making the revenue that adobe
did make friend professionals more
consistent and reliable
at the same time though adobe didn't
make it that much harder to pirate their
software and this was intentional adobe
is a massive tech company and they could
easily make their software unparable if
they wanted to i mean it literally took
the fbi 13 years to simply crack the
iphone's passcode lock so i'd be willing
to bet that adobe 21000 employees could
easily make their software unpiratable
however adobe knows that everyone who is
able to pay for the software does pay
for it here's the thing adobe's entire
customer base is creatives who know
firsthand how hard it is to create and
run a business
and while some of these creatives may
complain about adobe's pricing i'd be
willing to bet that 98 of creative
professionals who can afford adobe
software do indeed pay for it myself
included
now of course there's a two percent who
are unethical and immoral
but for the most part creatives are
willing to pay a dopey 600 per year to
legally get the software that makes
their entire career possible with that
being said making adobe software
unpiratable wouldn't really increase
adobe's revenue however it would cut off
up-and-coming creatives from even trying
the software
so john knew strategically made her
software difficult to pirate but not
impossible and i think this is perfectly
showcased in how they address pirated
software a few years ago adobe launched
something called adobe software
integrity service this software comes
along with all of adobe's creative apps
and is able to detect if the software
you're using is pirated
if it is pirated every time you open
premiere pro or photoshop it will tell
you that the software is pirated but
guess what it doesn't actually prevent
you from using the application
it simply reminds you every time that
you're using pirated software and i
think this approach embodies shantanu's
entire tenure as ceo and why he's such
an admired leader
chanting doesn't lead by force he leads
by integrity and transparency adobe
could disable the pirated software from
being used right when they detect that
it's not genuine or if they don't want
to do that they could at the very least
run ads on pirated software to partially
monetize it but they don't even do that
they simply notify users that they know
that it's pirated software and they try
to encourage users to pay for adobe
software by appealing to their morals
and ethics
this is the same approach continue uses
with all of his employees
nowadays many tech companies are under
the false impression that they can buy
the loyalty of their employees they pay
absurd salaries like two hundred
thousand four hundred thousand five
hundred thousand dollars per year yet
they're not able to hold on to their
employees
take a look at someone like mark
zuckerberg he pays his employees
extremely well and gives them every
amenity you can think of the median
salary itself at facebook is 240 000 per
year
yet facebook also had the highest
turnover rate in silicon valley until
this year
meanwhile the median salary at adobe is
134 000 per year
this isn't a low salary by any means but
it's also not absurdly high i like to
tech neighbors across the street adobe
also doesn't have free restaurants on
campus and they don't give their
employees free company cars
but what they do give their employees is
absolute freedom there's no clocking in
or clocking out
there's no manager nitpicking everything
you do and there's no one forcing you to
even do anything chanting believes that
great employees are self-motivated and
that their self-output is far superior
to anything that can be forced out of
them now of course if you abuse this
freedom and slack off you're gonna get
fired
but employees who use this freedom
responsibly love it
in fact most of the reviews on glassdoor
and indeed cite workplace culture as the
best thing about adobe and considering
all of this i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that adobe ranks
number two in north america for best
company culture only beaten out by
google and as shantanu expected this
insane performance in the employee and
customer satisfaction categories has
carried over to adobe's financials when
chanting became ceo in 2007 adobe was
profiting about 500 million per year
today they're profiting 5 billion per
year the company has consequently grown
from a 20 billion dollar company to a
320 billion dollar company and that's
how shantanu blew up adobe while staying
in the good graces of his customers
employees and investors do you wish your
boss was like continue or if you're in a
leadership role are you like shantanu
comment that down below
also drop a like if you think all
leaders should lead like chantinew and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]